this video was made possible by a way
get 20 off your away suitcase by going
to awaytravel.com
wendover and using the code wendover at
checkout
and quickly once you finish this video
there are two others to watch
a behind the scenes video on my brand
new personal channel and my appearance
on star talk where i appear
on camera for the first time both are
linked in the description
suppose we're in a cave right now this
is a cave
and there's maybe 10 of us we have a
mini family tribe
and i say you know i want to go out and
see what's on the other side of that
mountain
we can see it from here and then you say
no no we have
cave problems we have to fix first fix
all the cave problems first
then you can go out on the mountain and
that's what it sounds like to me
when i hear people say we have problems
on earth let's fix those
before we go into space and here's earth
this speck
of dirt orbiting an ordinary star and
there's this vastness of the universe
that is waiting for us
it beckons
[Music]
the commercial space industry is heating
up 50 years ago
outer space was reserved for the most
powerful of nations
the most dominant governments but today
there's a democratization of space
commercial industry is inching us closer
to the cosmos
and in the process there's a growing
interdependence between what's happening
hundreds of miles
up in space and down below on earth the
commercial space industry
using multi-million dollar satellites
and rockets is increasingly playing a
part in our everyday lives
you may think of this industry as a new
phenomenon you may have only started
hearing about profit-seeking space
enterprise in the past few years
but in reality this has been going on
for decades
our founder walter scott founded the
company in his garage in palo alto
uh 25 years ago this is dan jablonski
he's president of one of the commercial
space companies that you might not have
heard of digital globe
they might not be as flashy as spacex or
as exciting as virgin galactic
but they've been flying satellites since
before elon musk
even graduated college in fact they were
the very first american company to be
granted a license
to take high resolution pictures from
space and that
is essentially what they do they take
pictures from space
but it's a lot more complicated than it
sounds to take those images from space
you need satellites and digitalglobe has
five of them
so the five satellites we have on orbit
are goi one
worldview one worldview two worldview
three and you're noticing a trend here
worldview four
um the first of those was launched in
2007.
uh the most recent was launched in 2016.
and
they have an expected life of over 10
years each and these
are really good satellites world view 4
for example
digital globe's newest satellite has a
pixel size of 12 inches
that means that this satellite orbiting
383 miles above earth
can clearly see a single sheet of paper
placed in a parking lot
horizontally that's like if a camera in
toronto took a picture that could
clearly identify
the individual eyes of the statue of
liberty in new york
it is insanely high resolution with a 30
centimeter pixel you can actually pick
up
road markings you can see the lines on
the road whether they're straight or
dashed lines you can see whether there
are turn arrows there
whether there's a stop word on the road
markings
you can even pick up some of the traffic
signs and traffic light sizes
the potential uses of such high quality
imagery
are endless but how do the satellites
even work
first off it's good to know that our
satellites are in a low earth orbit
which means that they actually they
don't they're not like a geosatellite
that sits up in a fixed orbit and stays
over one place in the planet some
satellites are specifically designed to
stay directly over one position for
their whole service lives
their orbits are significantly higher
above earth so the time it takes for
them to complete an orbit
is exactly the same as the time it takes
the earth to make a full rotation
so relative to earth the satellite
doesn't move
at all this is incredibly useful for
certain uses
like communications when a
communications company launches a
satellite to broadcast tv or radio or
internet
they want that satellite to stay over
their particular service area
directv for example the american
satellite tv company
want their satellites to stay over the
u.s because that's their service area
if they weren't able to put their
satellites into geosynchronous orbit
they would have to launch enough
satellites to cover the entire world
even if they were only broadcasting to
the us so
directv want their satellites to stay
over one area
because they're broadcasting to one area
but digitalglobe on the other hand
want their satellites to move because
they're imaging
the entire world each of our satellites
right now are
in sun synchronous orbits so what that
means is that the orbital plane that the
satellite is flying around
in stays in the same orientation
relative to the sun
all the time simplified that means that
any given satellite passes over any
given location
on earth at the exact same time every
day world view 3 for example
always orbits above the points on earth
where it's 10 30 a.m
when it passes over denver it's 10 30 in
denver when it passes over paris it's 10
30 in paris
and when it passes over tokyo it's 10 30
in tokyo
how this works is that essentially with
each pass over the light side of earth
the orbit advances relative to the earth
at the same rate
as the sunlight advances this orbit type
is crucial because a lot of what
satellite imaging is about
is detecting change from day to day
month to month
or year to year and an image taken at 10
30 am is going to look
very different than one taken at 6 pm
this orbit type allows the satellite to
pass over
the entirety of earth once per day at
the same time
so the light conditions look the same
the satellites do of course
need to be told what to do and that all
comes down to four people
in one room so this is our mission
operations
control center this is where we fly the
five satellites on orbit
and really inside this room is what we
consider our time
dominant real-time activities from
choosing making the final choices of
what images we're going to collect in
the next
several minutes to the next several
hours these four individuals are
controlling
billions of dollars worth of satellites
this whole company
the thousands of employees and hundreds
of millions of dollars in revenue
all exist to organize and fund what
these four
individuals are doing sitting and
piloting the satellites above in space
the mission operations center is of
course staffed 24 7
since while it's nighttime in the u.s
it's daytime in asia and australia
the satellite vehicle operator's main
task is to load plans onto the
satellites of which images to take when
to monitor that the satellites are
operating correctly and to assure that
the satellites won't collide with other
satellites or space junk
the central screens at the front show
the current locations of each of the
five satellites
while the one to the left displays other
information such as the total number of
times each satellite has orbited around
the earth
and how much time they have until the
satellite loses signal
you see in order for satellites to
function they need to be able to
communicate with the ground
and that's done with ground stations
these antennas communicate to satellites
using what are essentially
super high powered wi-fi signals the
ground station's digital globe uses are
able to receive about a gigabyte of
information
every second from the satellites each of
those antennas around the world see each
satellite several times a day
and so as that as as we go through the
day we accumulate about seven terabytes
of raw imagery off the satellites
through that gigabit connection
satellites can only communicate with the
ground stations while they have a line
of sight with the antenna
so due to the curvature of the earth in
the view of any given ground station
the satellite will eventually dip below
the horizon therefore
each ground station only has a limited
operating range
the exact locations of ground stations
are understandably kept secret but if
there was one in germany for example it
would communicate with the digital globe
satellites exclusively while they passed
over europe
the fact that these satellites have to
by nature pass over the entire world is
actually however
quite useful not only does this let
digital globe map the entire world
but they also use the extra capacity for
humanitarian efforts
it's um it's actually easier for us on
the humanitarian global development side
because we have much more capacity
over a lot of these areas there's a lot
more demand for our satellites over
developed countries for instance right
so people are typically for commercial
applications much more interested in
the us or europe or some of these more
developed areas
versus sub-saharan africa where we just
generally speaking have much more
ability to test the constellation and to
collect those imagery
so it's actually an opportunity for us
to support those use cases
much more than than others for instance
digitalglobe partners with the gates
foundation to map
every single building structure in rural
zambia so aid workers now know things
like how many bed nets vaccines or food
to bring to communities that were
previously
unmapped there are few companies the
size of commercial space companies that
rely
on so few assets what makes digital
globe for example
run are those five satellites and to get
those
to space to the place where they make
money they had to put them on rockets
which tend to from time to time blow up
it's always a little bit of a nail biter
as you come up to a launch
we put an enormous capital investment
into the satellites
the launch vehicle and it all comes down
to a one-hour event
lifting off from the ground and going
into orbit and that's a that can be a
little bit of a nerve-wracking period
but certainly a very exciting one at the
same time
an average of one in 20 rocket launches
fail
and then on top of that some satellites
fail once they reach orbit
which makes the space business risky
companies like digital globe will
therefore purchase
enormously expensive insurance policies
on their satellites
in case the launch or the satellite
itself fails if they didn't
one bad launch could spell the end for
the company
of course some launch providers are much
more reliable than others
united launch alliance the launch
provider that digitalglobe used for
their current five satellites
has not had a launch failure in its
11-year history
insurance rates for ula would be
relatively low while insurance rates for
a newer launch provider such as orbital
atk or blue origin
would be comparatively high nonetheless
the cost of newer launch providers with
insurance included is now
often less than the older more reliable
launch companies
but how does digital globe fund their
exploits what keeps those satellites
flying
how do they make their money our largest
customer is the us government and we've
been very proud to be their mission
partner for over
a decade and a half coming up on two
decades now it used to be that the
commercial satellite industry was
essentially focused
on one major customer governments
in the past the us government has been
the single largest customer
of the few commercial space companies
that there were thanks to its enormous
defense spending
but today as commercial customers
contract commercial space companies
the business is spreading globally over
the past decade
the customer base has become more
international and more diversified
our other customers are are
international customers who who may
be us allies or maybe technology
companies across the world
we go deep in the telecommunications
infrastructure online mapping
energy industries mining industries
forestry applications there's really a
huge variety of customers
but the most obvious ones are those
mapping companies
if you've ever used google maps you're
using our imagery if you've ever used
apple maps you're using our imagery if
you ever
look and do a crowdsourcing project in
openstreetmap you're using our imagery
as well
but perhaps the single most promising
use of earth imagery
is with autonomous vehicles having good
solid current satellite imagery
is an integral part of how autonomous
vehicles work
these vehicles can't just rely on their
internal sensors to understand
their surroundings they need a view from
above
as we think about autonomous vehicles
it's not okay to update the image
once a quarter once a year even once a
week
it needs to be they really need imagery
that's coming in
much much faster than that to deal with
changes in traffic conditions changes in
roads
uh crashes etc uber which is developing
autonomous cars
is already a customer of digital globe
for navigation purposes
and as more and more companies move into
the autonomous vehicle race the
competition between
earth observation companies for their
business is likely to heat up
there are plenty of other emerging uses
as well which as an ensemble
are growing the demand for earth imagery
day by day
it is a tremendously fast growing
industry
but satellite imagery by itself really
isn't worth much
you need something more i would say that
our customers
are demanding more actionable
information
faster than ever translation customers
want data they want the information
embedded in the images
for that there's another company radiant
solutions
so today customers the big challenge is
around where it used to be
more of uh hey we just need to get an
answer now it's more of
how do we deal with all this all of this
data and how do we answer the more
complex questions because they are
getting more complex
and they're getting even harder to
answer now by virtue of being inundated
with data
radiant solutions would describe
themselves as a geospatial analytics
company
they take satellite imagery and
translate it into information
we're able to take in vast amount of
data and make sense of it to produce
insight
they answer big questions a logging
company might ask a question like
what's the density of trees in this
particular region of canada
before purchasing new land and radiant
would be able to look at
hundreds or thousands or millions of
square miles of imagery to tell them how
many trees there are
now with so much imagery and such a big
world
you can't just do this all by hand at
least economically
for that reason there's been a huge
shift in the geospatial analytics
business
toward using artificial intelligence we
hear more and more now that data is kind
of like the new oil
well that's that's sort of true but the
data has to be
reliable there has to be high confidence
in the data so the ai
has to be good to train a machine to
find a red car for example
you need to show it thousands or
millions of examples of what a red car
looks like
but it's very different for a machine to
look for a red car in an urban
environment as it is to find a red car
in snow
so not only are you training the models
to look for that object
but you also have to train it on
where to find it regionally it is hugely
complicated
but that's why these guys are in
business to answer
complicated questions some data however
isn't
in the visual spectrum some data is
hidden
but luckily there's a special satellite
just for that
in the old days it was just please get
me good solid image pixels to use
and i'll go figure out how to use them
today
particularly in the commercial space
it's all about information
that's paul kennedy vice president of
ground systems at mda
they've been in business since 1969.
their most visible project was on
developing the canadarm for the space
shuttles and international space station
as a longtime player in the industry
they serve a variety of functions from
developing space robotics to building
satellite ground stations
but one of their most valuable assets is
that special satellite
radar sat2 while most earth observation
satellites image using the visual
spectrum
what we can see with our own eyes
radarsat-2
uses radar radar is an active
pulse so the satellite actually sends it
a beam of of energy to the ground
and reads back reads back what it gets
back from the earth and that gives us a
couple of
interesting advantages in in sar for one
radar can see through clouds and
darkness it doesn't matter what the
light and weather conditions are
it's all the same for radar sat2 now mda
is a canadian company and it's no
coincidence that a canadian company
operates this satellite
just like the us government is a major
customer of digital globe
the canadian government is a major
customer of mda
and here's the thing about canada the
weather is terrible and it's always dark
quite literally in northern canada where
the sun stays down
for the entire winter it's no
coincidence that the company that works
so closely with the canadian government
operates the satellite that can see
through clouds and night
without radarsat 2 the canadian
government would be blind
they would have no way of monitoring
huge swaths of their territory in the
high arctic for months
out of the year with new launch
providers emerging such as blue origin
and rocket lab and spacex
the cost of launching material into
space is plummeting
now this is useful to these companies at
least in some ways
with lower launch costs digital globe
and mda can launch more satellites which
means
more data for radiant solutions but that
also makes it easier for competitors to
launch satellites
the earth imagery business is growing
but so is the competition
the best known earth imagery startup
planet is launching a constellation
of small satellites while digital globe
satellites are the size of a bus
planet's smallest are the size of a
toaster
with the smaller size development and
launch costs are lower
while in the past starting a space
imagery company required hundreds of
millions or billions of dollars in
funding
the emergence of small stats means that
it's enormously easier to break into the
satellite imagery business nowadays
but there is a key difference between
these two companies
digital globe's satellites capture
imagery with a pixel size of 12 inches
while planet's primary satellite
constellation captures imagery with a
pixel size
of 10 to 15 feet at a much lower cost
there are certain uses for high
resolution imagery and there are certain
other uses for low cost imagery
so in some ways these two companies
aren't even direct competitors
nonetheless the space industry is
changing
growing and becoming more competitive so
the established companies
need to adapt united launch alliance
knows that
airbus knows that aryan space knows that
and digital globe
mda and radiant know that too so they
made a change
these three companies are now one along
with a fourth company
a spacecraft manufacturing company
called ssl that will be covered in a
future video
these are the entities that make up the
newest powerhouse
in the space technology business this
merger wasn't necessarily
in response to heavy competition but
rather at least from an outsider's
perspective
a preemptive strike to establish
themselves as a major
international player before the
commercial space industry truly lifts
off
increasingly the more traditional
aerospace and defense
companies that have been supplying
technology in space
have been able to provide the
performance
but the cost has been extremely high
maxar is now a fully vertically
integrated company
in the earth imagery space for example
they'll do everything from building
satellites to operating them
to extracting data from imagery by
performing all the steps in this process
internally maxar lowers its costs and
this also puts them
in the same league as airbus as one of
the very few end-to-end
integrated space companies the
commercial space industry as a whole is
doing a phenomenal job of making
access to orbital space commonplace the
routine
steps of space activities
are slowly being seeded to private
enterprise that could do it faster
better cheaper
we're now at a place where launching a
satellite to low earth orbit
is unexceptional that's exactly what we
want easy access to space
and for near space that exists right now
getting beyond earth's orbit though
outside our cosmic neighborhood
into deep space that's still tough the
problem is that private enterprise
by its very nature needs to make money
companies and their leaders are beholden
to their investors to make money
if they're not then they're not a
company companies can
and do make money with deep space but
only through developing and building
technologies for nasa
and other government agencies there is
zero commercial demand
for deep space technology today going to
new planets
to new solar systems exploring space
that really doesn't make money many
people who think about commercial space
i think they're over predicting what
their role will be they're imagining
commercial space
leading a space frontier but to lead a
space frontier is expensive
and it's not an obvious return on the
investment
you might do it as a vanity project
there are enough billionaires in the
world they could all pool their money
jeff bezos bill gates
elon musk they could do a vanity project
and send humans to mars let's say
but that's not a business model and
it would get a lot of attention but is
that something you can sustain no
it would be a one-off when people
imagine a future of space
and industry they're imagining a
sustained business case of course
you could have said the same thing about
the space race 60 years ago
that was exploration however in the long
term
it was an investment that paid off
because space
now makes money space today is an
integral part
of what we know and what we can do on
the surface of the planet
communications imagery
climate science defense and intelligence
and security applications
all of those are seamlessly enabled
by space technologies without most of us
who go through our daily lives
not even thinking about it the
difference between commercial
enterprise and governments is time
commercial enterprises need to think
about investments that pay off
within the lifetime of their
shareholders so you're always thinking
about
what is the return on the investment
you're making
how long will it take you to achieve the
returns on the investment
and what's the probability that the r d
you're putting in
will be successful while companies look
at investments in terms of years
governments can look at investments in
terms of decades or centuries
because governments transcend
generations
the innovation that will occur by
bringing humans to mars and beyond will
absolutely make money in the very long
term
but right now it would take an enormous
amount of money
that few people want to risk you could
point to elon musk as an exception to
this rule
he more than anyone understands the
value of super long-term investments
like going to mars
but he also understands that he's alone
in that individuals
don't want to invest in something that
won't make money until
after they're dead musk has stated that
he has no plans to take spacex public
until after a successful mission to mars
which means that for the moment
the company is almost acting more as an
organization
he's funneling the money from launches
which make money
into exploration which doesn't
governments need to lead
the way because they have the longer
time horizons that they can think about
and monetize when they do that
once they lead the way they have now
quantified the risks
and you know the cost and where the the
friendlies are and the hostels and the
whatever are the things that would
compromise your mission
they've already figured this out then if
they do it right you then hand that to
private industry
that then makes a buck off of it then
the government can tax that
if they so choose maxar technologies and
its four businesses meanwhile
absolutely innovate including in deep
space technologies
but they're not going to put the pieces
together to go to mars by themselves
because that's not a good investment one
should be careful to realize that this
coming era of commercialized space
does not necessarily translate into a
renaissance of space exploration
commercial industry is not a substitute
for nasa
or the esa or any other government
institution
they are collaborators they can make the
government's job easier and cheaper
but they cannot replace those whose jobs
are to go
where no human has gone before the next
few decades and centuries
can be the era of space exploration
but for that you need a public you need
an electorate
that understands that anything good
anything truly worthwhile
takes time
there are so many thanks i have to give
for help with this video
but one is to away not only for making
this video possible through sponsorship
but also for literally carrying my
possessions over the 15
000 miles i traveled while making this
video and unfortunately that number is
not a mistake
i've now owned my away suitcase for
almost a year have traveled all over the
world with it
and i love it the suitcase is just
solidly built
you can feel it and has a built-in yet
removable battery a laundry bag a laptop
sleeve
and a compression system so you can pack
more into a smaller space
best of all for how good it is the away
suitcase is sold for an amazing price
and it's at an even more amazing price
if you go to awaytravel.com
and use the code wendover at checkout to
get twenty dollars off
your away suitcase they're so confident
that you'll love the product that all
away suitcases have a lifetime warranty
and a hundred day unconditional return
policy it's
quite literally no risk and they made
this enormous video possible so if you
need a suitcase for life
check out awaytravel.comwendover and use
the code wendover
at checkout i also have to give a huge
thanks to max our technologies
especially kristin carringer and turner
brinton for letting me film this video
as it takes an enormous amount of work
to allow cameras into such a high
security environment
lastly as i mentioned at the beginning i
appeared on neil degrasse tyson's show
star talk and also launched a new
personal channel where i made a behind
the scenes video
for that appearance both are linked in
the description and on screen now
thanks again for watching and i'll see
you again in three weeks for another
wendover productions video